[Music]
they're here hey whatever hello everyone
uh happy 2019 they're still readjusting
everything there I found our microphones
for good oh it's good to see all of you
yeah welcome back everybody
I know this is gonna be a really fun
thing for everyone who was here for our
last room where we said hot this is our
last time we're ever gonna play moss
tour honor on ps4 on the ps4 that was a
lie so we're back and we're putting her
on the ps4 a new crossover event that
they have it's been a whole year and
we're still playing Monster Hunter
nothing's changed
it's beautiful I love it the game that
keeps giving so we've got a new
crossover event where we get some just
gonna put the game in cuz I'm while I'm
talking huh we get to go and get some
Assassin's Creed gear so there's some
layered armor for the the newest or one
of one of the newer Assassin's Creed
protagonists from the second to last
game and we also get to get a new mantle
which increases your attack power from
attacking from when you're hiding I
believe yes so we're gonna try to get
some of that stuff going we have here
I'm gonna move it because I realize it's
very close to the actual there we go
we've got a session ID up we're playing
on the PlayStation 4 you guys can join
us and help us get this Assassin's Creed
please help us because it's actually a
really tough looking fight yeah there's
a lot of stuff going on uh yeah we're
playing ps4 because it's not available
yet on the PC um I'm kind of worried
I don't think become like parity with it
because I'm a little worried I switched
over to the PC version recently yeah
yeah and I'm I'm much preferring it it
runs smooth it looks great
my brothers got on PC so we can playing
together it's a lot of fun but I'm like
man I hope that expansion comes out like
that it seemed yeah that ice-born like
please come out at the same time don't
make me wait five months I think we're
gonna have to
they shouldn't though like I mean they
have to bring it parity like they need
to do it destiny did where destiny was
delayed but eventually it caught up
right yeah yeah and it was like I it's
fine now
so I'm hoping for that along with the
Geralt stuff which is still on the way
as well I believe
a couple months before yeah that should
be real soon but yeah a lot of people
hanging out in the chat saying court
can't wait for the ice-born dlc feel
that a lot of people saying they love
dirty arty dirty artis on the way yeah
he had to take a break he had to go into
hibernation and go to hibernation for
the winter but he's gonna come back with
a vengeance
yeah I like our words would imagine that
would come back I want put words in
anyone's mouth but at the very feel like
next week maybe next next week yeah
everyone still kind of show the games
we're not showing the game I'll double
check just to be sure I mean I trust the
chap more than I probably should
but I'm gonna do I'm gonna do it
the Phoenix yeah yeah see we're in there
I'm talking about someone trying to
trick me
the Phoenix since the roller coaster of
emotions we told you Phoenix we'd never
be able to play with them again and then
here we are here we are playing with
them again it's a it's a New Year
miracle sure I'm gonna accept this this
quest so also on the PC I've been
playing with the charge blade and I've
gotten very good at it which means I've
also not been playing with the doom
blades which is I have on this character
you so that's gonna be a little little
run gosh there's so many things to fight
here yeah this characters definitely oh
I still feel bad that I'm abandoning my
my playstation boy though like your
character yeah I love him so much just
recreate him on the PC why I should but
I'm also already like 30 40 hours into
my my PC character you cannot you can
change your oh yeah get one for your
parents changing although maybe not
gender change
maybe well I can fine I'll look into it
we'll see where we are yeah um I'm gonna
see if I can change my equipment
so I think why is this a secrete in this
game crossovers man uh a lot of people
might not know but Monster Hunter has
been doing crossovers for a very very
long time one of my favorite crossovers
they did this is a shot at - I guess the
person who's telling us to play middle
you're solid but there's a really good
crossover with Metal Gear Solid yeah hey
men we should we should play metal gear
at some point well we do office I was
gonna say we've been we can't we've been
trying to do office Metal Gear plays
yeah just on our for funsies
you guys ready I'm just actually
shouldn't double check my equipment at
first but we should get that going oh
yeah I should probably do that I might I
have a loadout for this it's got a
sleeping of a sleepy axe I should use
the sleepy axe wonderful oh wow I have
no man this character's all sorts of
messed up yeah I just want any herbs or
anything really I don't have any herbs
that seems ridiculous what did I do with
this character oh this guy's got a look
about him yeah this is this is what I
want this is my I attack one okay I'm
starting to remember where everything's
at I do this extra finis yeah I'm ready
to go don't get some large barrels in
here today I get my food on yeah I did
that in there and also if you do join in
and you see that we're off doing a hunt
don't don't feel bad don't hunt with
other people who are in here yeah it's a
good way to get people going for so you
guys can uh yeah the the spirit of
Monster Hunter I always encouraged
people to help other people you know you
tell that guy on the right that I like
him that would be you
is it me oh well thank you yeah I
believe you should you should if it's
not me if it is me I should like both of
us both were both pretty cool people I
like to think that
but you know see is it just the skin so
one outfit is a cosmetic skin that just
goes over your outfit but then the and
that's the Biak one the Ezio one is an
actual cement yeah it's like a piece of
armor so it's it's like one of the the
like the like coats or Poncho's that you
throw over and where you just become an
assassin coming assassin right then in
there sounds pretty good let me out of
the cryo tube when you guys play Monster
Hunter hey it sounds like there's gonna
be a lot of Monster Hunter so you're
gonna get your not be getting a lot of
sleep yeah Monster Hunter is still
happening in the year of our Lord 2019
it's very true is this game on the Xbox
one yes Gord it is stop wasting your
time increase your viewership do we're
waiting for people the we're building up
our crew yeah there's a whole process
you know just hop into a monster hunter
you got it food you gotta get your
people there's there some do some emotes
you gotta hang out also it we're we're
here for you guys or we're here Monster
Hunters a a backdrop you know appear to
have a good time hang out with you guys
I hope all of you had a good good break
if you had one oh god they're all inside
of this small enclosed area I know I
know
it's just this is a bad deal we got we
got a bad deal hopefully it's a one out
of nope they're all there at once
awesome I was gonna say maybe one at a
time but I don't think they like they'd
open up the door or something
well actually nope well there's two of
them okay should we get forget pickleboy
and Darrin's over in the flash dog okay
probably probably no to Karen started up
maybe or we've started oh you want to
hit that rock on the on the pickleboy
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay has anyone got some stones
I think you gotta hit the open I'm gonna
go for it I think it's a switch right
here oh it is a switch shoot okay
somebody try and get him leave him over
oh he's jumping up to you oh they're
both okay
oh hello oh jeez this is going real bad
no this is this is fine this is all
according to plan
Oh God don't mind me I'm just gonna
remember how to use the dual blades oh
you guys got your your coats on that's a
it's a very good call your your bandit
Mantle's at you are victorious in the
chat
Ezio it's you I love your video games
doing it oh he's eating him ah missed
good effort though I was like this is it
it's now or never
watching that uh that poco boy devourer
yeah he is I guess I didn't think about
that that they were gonna fight each
other that kind of does work to our
advantage
ouch so I'm wondering what the UH what's
the Assassin's Creed tie into this like
why why these monsters well because
usually there's kind of like like a Mega
Man was like 302 Garen's that were small
cuz they're like rush wondering what
what's going on here
metaphor for the Templars ah all of the
dinosaurs are temple artists that's
that's what it is yeah that make sense
I love that one keep it oh my gosh
so yeah this is definitely a perfect
time to be talking about this but it's
the first stream of the year so of
course the best thing to think about is
what what is everyone excited to play
what's what's everyone looking forward
to cuz we got a lot of stuff coming up
in like January in February that's gonna
be real fun for me it's a resonable to
remain
yeah residents remake is less than a
month away
I guess Kingdom Hearts that's the thing
double May Cry is in like March Wow I
was he was on top of you that was one
hit I'm cool I don't know hard time
finding a way to like ours mine go for
it geez
I thought I had nutrients on me but I
did not characters that's not very well
built cuz I haven't like been messing
with them in a while so I feel like you
just can't we kind of like fell into the
like we're just doing hunts on this when
we do it for not like oh crap some I got
I got some good hits in there that was
the spree alright oh man you're knock
them both down thrilling action
happening on Ben screen that none of you
can see just just some just some boring
switch ax nonsense
no one gets excited about switch axes
anymore I put that monster to sleep
we may anthem that comes not really soon
yeah I'm excited to like play that I
don't know if I'm gonna stick with it
because I have no idea what the end
games like sure as a bio fan I'm very
curious about it when can i smoosh the
robots that's where I am now they they
have already said you can't do that why
what up Oda Garen she's got going on pal
how's it going dude
the way here ah stop screaming at each
other drop a health booster back over
here behind the pickle boy
hello Jaeger Rooney's
Omega BB material excuse me hello don't
mind me
this is the year that sims 5 is do we go
by Sims 3s precedent dude I'm in for new
Sims game give me give me more excuses
to play the sims I'll do it anytime
also I seem to have fallen off like the
Train of what school in the sims now was
it like a couple of months ago when
everyone was talking about smash
characters and EA tweeted out like I put
Bob pancakes and smash I think ice
literally stood up in the office and was
like who the hell is Bob pancakes it's
an excellent question and why would we
choose them to represent the Sims and
not like Mortimer or Bella God you know
I'm still on that Katy Katy Perry oh
yeah cover is where she just did her
songs and Simlish the Black Eyed Peas
did that as well for the dead I feel
like we didn't really do much of that
work but I'll take it the pickle boy ate
took care of it for us I don't know if I
want to try this but I'm gonna do it
anyway do it man my gift I'm gonna get
that but you do that carve all right
let's do it
oh boy oh my god I got something out of
them I mean we knew the risk
yikes do it again we're doing right
running yes we're all doing it oh that's
a bad idea
one of us needs to be the distraction
you know I'm gonna do it I'm gonna run
over here where's the where's the dragon
ate her at is that could it go god is
good to go did you get the carb come
over here I didn't yeah there we go I
hit him in the face so he's gotta come
know Assassin's equals clickbait dude
not at all man we are doing the fight
that gets you the assassins are this is
this is a process it's now mob Starworks
man you do this fight you get the
material
lord shaxx has joined the session oh
dude perfect Guardians showed them the
true meaning of Christmas oh I hope he
replaces all his like stuff like you can
make your custom messages he makes them
all like Shaq's core
I'll be really good Jackson The Drifter
are are the best parts of destiny now
someone's saying how they should make
one person was like oh I I whenever I
have to do equipment management I just
go hang out by shacks so I can hear them
talk ya know the person said they should
add shacks quotes are just encouragement
they like just like but but like like
really polite like wholesome like Oh
like don't worry Guardians like you'll
you'll do better next time
everything will be okay you don't have
to turn on voice chat if you don't want
to so shacks is really good I just I
kind of want to just like if I were to
play destiny I would just be to do the
PvP just so I could call wait here oh no
is that like it's like a good thing or a
bad thing
what like I wouldn't want to like
actively take part in like raids or
whatever they're doing now I just want
to like bounce between crucible and the
the new mode with a drifter right now
Oh sound bad I've gotta I've just fallen
off of destiny very hard at this point
how the dragon eater is ready like to uh
move them over here yeah if you want to
try and attract him over follow me
okay
here it is here it is here it is it hit
it hit it hit it yeah those were in the
head - it's very angry excellent
excellent
hey crime it's good to see you well I'd
be about really mad cuz I think they
were under the impression that you were
like like it just gives it that you know
that you got to like know there's
someone saying there's actual assassins
and here you got to play with like I
think people thought like you just
played like an assassin oh no it's it's
just like gear stuff like they have been
doing it it's pretty standard stuff for
for monster hunter at this point yeah I
think the the Geralt was gonna be much
more substantial maybe the thing I think
but I kind of looking for yeah the
garret one is you actually play as
Geralt and you do like a series of
special missions but yeah they're not
gonna like you can't really do like
assassin stuff in this that's how it
works yes so the the Assassin's Creed
crossover stuff if if you're not sure
you don't know is you can get by x armor
as like a thing for your character to
wear mm-hmm and then you can also get a
special mantle that lets you get higher
attack damage from being hidden that
just hint basically turns you into like
Ezio from the waist up go for that tail
I don't want to like knock you guys over
now please do
as long as they go coach from hundred
I'm all good you can you can get a quote
300 there you go
oh now that I have I use charge plate on
PC I am excited to do the Dante outfit
so I can get the charge bite yeah that
charge blades really high total area so
sorry for the click my comment I did not
know its skin no worries man okay it's
alright sometimes like you aren't sure
and it's it's good to just ask you know
yeah
and then we can we can help you out
we're more than happy to explain to you
this game is so difficult it can get
pretty tough on these higher rank stuff
also I feel bad because my character is
not really well optimized cuz we I only
really pull it out every time we do a
stream so I'm not actively playing with
them that's why I'd like to switch over
the PC since I've started using that
character more regularly yeah I wouldn't
be able to even if this event was on the
PC I actually wouldn't be far enough to
do it anyway so yeah this is still a
hiring quest right yes it's a I think a
rank 9 now you did it so now now we got
to get ready for the elder dragon to
come out yeah was it stay Ostra hey
Oscar I believe the female 1 oh boy we
might die we we might die Dante you can
still get that yes so during they have
um seasonal events they do for like the
like the cherry blossom event and they
have like a summer thing and they have
like a winter fall one in a winter one
during those events they bring back all
of the old limited events so you can
redo them and have a chance to get them
which is fantastic
I think every game should handle it that
way yeah cuz otherwise it becomes just
like no you didn't buy this game until
now you missed out on Dante so when they
bring that when they bring when they do
like the spring one that'll be my chance
to grab Dante on the PC so I'm pretty
excited for that
okay guess we're just gonna wait for him
to show up yeah I think they're gonna
come out of one of these doors fun I'm
just gonna get it's probably this door
over here you want to see oh there are
some barrels set up over there people on
top of it I think all the cannons might
actually be destroyed so we can't like
use those how the rock is set up again
oh they're here yeah they are
oh boy Oh fun all right I didn't fought
them on this character yet yes get him
in the middle that's not the middle
that's right where I am isn't moon
astral like a like okay fall fall fall
football damn it no you got it AM yeah
yeah was 700 damage it's barely on the
tail yeah he moved and I was so worried
I messed that up I'm breaking all the
rules right now and you're not doing
this oh god that's a lot of damage wow
that looks really cool though
crimes do you want to play Monster
Hunter generations ultimate I'm up I
actually couldn't get into that one
it's it's a very different game it's a
very different game I'll be on it's like
world with my first monster on her I
really got into and going trying to go
back to generations it's very very
different
thanks I acknowledge that the game is
probably very good but I just I don't
think I can go backwards personally
there are a lot of very very good
changes they made for world and I even
after like playing so many master
hunters I actually I kind of prefer it
like there's the fact that I don't have
to carry like equipment I can move a
little bit one healing it's all like oh
it's casual type of stuff but I really
like it okay we're starting to an ante
on the same it's 20 18 mouth better
that's right crime it's going basket
words the assassin so we are currently
doing the quests that will get you the
materials to craft our assassin gear
that's what we're doing here's hoping
where we're not going to get
murdered here I'm not doing well what
well I'm the only one who's died right
so we still have I think we might have
had two deaths oh geez
so we're like one off Oh yikes that's
not a health items that's that's the
that's the fun time edge drink
I got an ancient potion
I also really like the tracking stuff in
the world like at the beginning you know
you have to do it so much later on no
later on because he kind of maximizing
oh good you mounted him I did it that's
got trying I've done my trademark thing
and I just did my trademark thing heck
yeah
why are you wearing the skins because
we're currently doing the quest to get
the skins we haven't gotten a chance to
do it yet so this is this is literally
our first attempt at it yeah that's the
whole idea is that we're we're showing
you how the fight works and we're gonna
try and get some skin hopefully we get
enough material yeah
you guys time for cyberpunk and I am
said hopefully it'll be released in the
fall I don't think it's coming out this
year yeah I have a very strong feeling
that it's gonna be way later kind of
thing I think it's gonna come out on the
next generation of consoles I don't
think it's coming out on this generation
it'll be interesting if it's one of
those games that kind of like straddles
the line yeah something tells me just
wow I think it'll be like uh launch or
near launch titles for the Xbox to if
they call it that
ah yes and the expo ps5 what are they
gonna call the next they put themselves
in a hole the Xbox they gotta just go
that round the box the box it's the bomb
I think it's the Xbox do you have that
of the perfect it's the only route you
can go this point dang any moved I'm
very glad that Nintendo kind of
abandoned their Wii oh me too
we boat yeah that was a bummer yeah it's
the Wii U I'm like no no no no I'm not
on board I get why they thought that was
a good idea cuz they're like the brand
recognition the Wii but it was so on is
the I got no question I don't I don't I
oh god you got this is is wii u better
or worse than mine yes new 3ds a--'s
worse because as a person who worked it
GameStop when that happened when someone
was like I'd like a new 3ds which like a
new 3d I'll do a 3d I was like Orrin
used 3d yes you I would like to use the
new 3d yeah like it's it was real-world
thumb and real real silly man I mean
Trekkie Baron jump on him um I'm very
tired
Oh God the so I think the new 3d s is
the worst name but the new 3ds is not as
bad because it was just a new iteration
of the 3ds on a new console the Wii U
was a new console and one people thought
it wasn't a new console yeah they
thought it was just like an add-on for
the Wii oh heck yeah we got some more
mounts stuff going on bring it down or
her down it's okay I'm gonna put some
barrels down when we knock them is it
tempered I have no clue to be honest I
don't think it is I don't think so I
didn't check the quest before we came in
I'm pretty sure it's not the crossover
stuff usually tends to not be like super
super hard but put down a barrel
there it is just gotta like he's gotta
take that that uh all rather that's got
the the Kim speculate from that's cool
because the Kim cycle actually if you
shoot the Kim sect at it it'll actually
activate the bombs yeah yeah
did Kim sickly was a lot of fun can
cycle a bit I've been watching him play
and it looks fun Zelda's join the online
session Zola I love your video games did
we got Selda in the game we got HT owned
chat this is great this is yeah this is
everything we could have asked for a
staged video staged video I mean is that
I think that's like a compliment it's
changed because we're because it seemed
like we're so good at this look is that
what's happening
good I'll take that or stay just like
I'm gonna need I'm gonna need you to
elaborate elaborate than what you're
referring to
nice nice nice nice nice so I'm picking
with a whole bunch of dragon pods yeah
this seems pretty good we had on him I
weren't doing pretty good health booster
right yeah they're getting there
Oh someone's got the uh come on just
move a little forward and hit that thing
yikes I need it back away I need to get
out of here I need to really get out of
here are they just immune to the the
stun trap because they're not either
they're not hitting it or they're just
immune to it so I think they're immune
to it dragon that sucks cuz you can't
you can't capture them oh my oh it's not
you guys it was a damn YouTube ad that
was on the channel so I know that oh no
worries no worries men thanks for the
clarification yeah we were just confused
I mean but you can also say it looks
like it's staged because we're so good
if you also want a compliment as we're
okay with that I'm down you know what
2019 I'm Connor right now does a year of
the compliment being nice - Pete's -
people like so let's all take a take a
step back be cool relax good say in the
last year I think our live chat has
gotten really nice you had a really good
stable live chat very rarely do I feel
like we get like we a lot of real bad
people in here yeah I was just saying
I'm gonna keep it real with you guys
there was a point in time where we'd be
like oh no YouTube chat yeah the YouTube
judges sucks
you the YouTube chat has gotten a lot
nicer but it's it's good now yeah like I
think it's I'm excited to talk to every
still gets rough when we do leg III and
stuff because you get a lot of people in
here and it's just naturally that many
people it's gonna kind of be
a bit of a [ __ ] show but I think our
regular our regular chats we get are
pretty good I'm pretty happy with you
guys so kudos to you guys yeah baby and
rad rad people thank you and also I'm
gonna use this opportunity to jump up
and do a quick Pleiades Rama and if you
hold on put on my voice okay and if you
enjoy yourself hanging out in our chat
please subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss a single stream we do we
stream every weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific
this is really hard to do while I'm
fighting this dragon we should get the
Smash Bros announced there to do a promo
for us really should and then we can
also have him do something like Joker
lines yeah or at it
we sure everywhere every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific Way over here so if you
need a I was gonna say if you need some
safety there's away from him I always
need safety but then he just showed up
so nevermind one minute so the dragon
ater can be used again yes everything
was everything's working out it's
perfect and also if you like John Luke
and I won one half of the crime boy
squad we do a show every Friday where we
play games with you guys can I join ya
the game if you can join the game if
you're on ps4 yes we're not on PC with
this one
I got rocks all the trap is ready to use
I might have messed up I definitely know
I know worries that's a tough one
that's a real it's like all the tails
there this is perfect
oh yeah we will play like fighting games
play Monster Hunter will play Halo was
really good time oh heck yeah oh the
dragonair would have been a cool way to
beat him though we have got it hey I'm
into it either way all right so see what
type of type of cool stuff we're gonna
get from this what can we build what I
really hope we got enough to make
something Janna make some armor
something oh I got a gym and a tail
somebody wants to know how we got Arthur
naked and dirty RT that is a glitch
right yes so it's like a glitch where
like if you a judge I sort of remember
Joey explaining it like you have to like
as you're going in to take a bath like
throw like a Molotov cocktail at the
door or something oh okay as as you do
to take your clothes off yeah and I
guess like it causes you to go in and
still like put Arthur in that state but
he gets kicked out because he's on fire
or something I don't it there's there's
probably something somewhere online how
to do it but yeah you do Xbox instead of
ps4 well we kind of jump around a bit
yeah so like yeah we'll do like Halo on
the Xbox we'll do Master Hunter on the
ps4 just cuz that's how much ps4
eventually probably PC once we get that
going and assuming they eventually get
parity with all the stuff would be nice
I know as far as monster and our Xbox
will probably not do that because that's
a whole I'm not gonna make it they're
scary it's a lot of stuff
guys are good people oh thank you yeah I
actually was not paying to have any
feathers I got did you I didn't see any
feathers I saw I get why saw there was
something else god oh god I hope we got
a feather we did that whole thing there
has to be a feather so it has to be a
feather there has to be a feather
somewhere rot destiny we don't do
destiny ourselves very much but Tate
hey doesn't David do Tate it's at a
David scenario we used to do destiny
semi-regularly I don't know if we still
do but whenever there's something like
big happens we'll usually have a regular
game we do at the moment cuz last year
it was like we did master an irregularly
and then tainted fortnight regularly and
then I believe he did do destiny
regularly for a little bit see I'm gonna
hope to the word find a new regular game
yeah anthem anthem will be regular I
don't know actually I could see that if
it's popular who knows yeah same guild
cards to receive so alright let's see
what I can do
did we get a feather started thank
goodness oh great okay so I've got one
feather out of two to get the layered
armor the by a grammar yeah okay so I
wonder does the armory lady have the
quest for the the layered armor the
layered armor is at the resource center
three get layered armor oh yeah there it
is specialized tool assassins hood so we
need four all together and I got one
she'll get monster hunter world for Xbox
does it required stay connected online
uh you can play solo yeah I don't think
you don't need to be connected to do it
I actually played most of my ps4
playthrough by myself
oh yeah it's it's a pretty good time
okay so um I'll have to do it at least
once more at least once where to get one
and one of the things how about that how
about I get one you get the other okay
I'll get the the mantle and you want to
get the the layered armor sounds good to
me
go buy some health items so that I
actually have some now we'll do the
fight one more time and then we'll
hopefully both get that armor but that's
nice that it's not it's not too much too
much you gotta do it four times normally
though that's a that's a it's a good
amount of times well you can knock that
out though in like a evening if you're
playing with some buddies and you all
want to do it yeah let's see
get me them potions there you go all
right I got into my box as well yeah I
need to fill up my my box we have a lot
of honey I don't know we'll find out
oh I've got like 200 potions that I just
went crazy and bought a bunch and then
crafted them okay apparently don't have
any honey no honey at all
oh no I buy honey from this dude see
about some barrel bombs
so 100 I guess I don't have any honey
really I don't
geez geez I've not been doing good with
this character that's it's it's one of
those things I could use I could use
this because it's an elder dragon I
could bring back my my longsword stupid
stuff that I used to do yeah I haven't
used a longsword in a while though me
that dick summoner jelly oh yeah that
thick jelly that's different it's
definitely what we're here for
oh man I'm gonna head back up to the
gathering hub sounds good see one of my
stats like with this that's not bad at
all apparently some job lobber made a
Bullwinkle reference in there question I
totally missed it I'm very sorry I have
very little bowling cool experience
outside of that one to be global
experience apparently and they remade
Rocky and Bullwinkle yeah that's so
that's the thing that's happening
interesting
this ain't no dirty Artie apparently
dirty Artie's like the thing it is yeah
we haven't even made like a dirty our
t-shirts yet what are we thinking I know
apparently for if you're not dirty Artie
and no one cares so I guess we'll just
name it
dirty Artie spot dirt no dirty spot look
at that that by Eck it looks real good
it's really good
oh they're gassing about it heck yeah
yeah that looks great any like actually
is by X like face and everything I think
you can uh like you can actually adjust
the color on it too so like that red is
customized that is true dang looks good
okay we are joining a quest yeah you
know post it up and I'll join on you
yeah
posta quest year okay
how many needs a voucher this time see
if I get a second one I'm gonna do the
same under dragon from elder dragon oh
god there are so many of these
everyone's trying to do it I didn't make
it in time
oh I got I got a ps4 error because
everyone went so fast oh you guys are
too quick I'm literally sitting here
next to him and I didn't beat you okay
alright ready I'm ready for it it's not
it there it is
Joanne I did it BAM I did it I did it
yeah I really appreciate all of you oh
look at that guy with his feathered cap
yeah that's that's from I missed that
one some like some special guild guild
type of nonsense that looks awesome
how do I get that I want that I'm gonna
eat a meal really quick room for one
more
I missed the the snowmen me too
Megaman how do that that's awesome there
was a Megaman event as well yeah yeah
Scott I got that then Megaman following
me around ah those who didn't make it in
does have fun well thank you thank you
for coming by for the last one
appreciate it
I'm just gonna double check that I
really I really don't have any honey no
I do I have honey he was lying to me I
think it's cuz it was I didn't have it
in my inventory why I can do it
cutter maybe I should I'm going to
actually use no I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick with the the long sword I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna do it this is who I
am
alright say I'm ready to ready to go do
it away off off to the races his Master
Hunter available on the switch so one of
the older Monster Hunters got ported to
the switch it's it's not as user
friendly as Monster Hunter world but
it's got like four times the monsters in
it yeah so if you can figure it out
you'll have content four days yeah but
also that does not mean like world is
about by any means though like lacking
content
oh no I'm definitely well over like two
or three hundred hours played on this I
think and it's still a very good time
see that's good this is good
take that rope lift okay so I'm going to
use a rock to distract one of them into
the middle okay I follow this and then
[Music]
or my ex just gonna hop on in there dude
as you do my act as that's fair he
didn't know he didn't know the plan
get in the middle get him in now I'll
try to run over I don't know if he's
following me though yes yes right okay
okay I got it
hold them there for a sec yeah yeah
there we go
excellent teamwork
well that was fantastic I like we're
already off to a great start
Oh to guaran still isn't jumping in yet
I'm okay with that
same that does not bother
please don't attack me you try it
giant pickle monster you
oh man
what happened I try to get the amount
but I
ah I'm just gonna keep trying this over
and over come on it's getting those the
sweet jumps judo sweet jumps man
someone's mounting him yeah there you go
somebody got him I think it's a hadouken
in there okay okay ah that's such a hard
thing to pull off but it's so cool when
you do it is yo he's down he's down
the other character that both now works
out in our favor though just like no kid
outta here that poor Oden Gary is just
here to get punished by yeah that's
literally it
he's not letting go of him either
through different people going on - like
equipment-wise
yeah
it's gonna hop on up so yeah both of
them with my slash it's real dangerous
oh yeah I jumped off of the ODA Karen
with my sword and came down on to the
other guy oh oh what is this game this
is monster hunter world playing on the
PlayStation 4 playing on the ps4 here
it's available on Xbox Playstation and
PC now and it's a it's a real good time
with your pals that indeed
there we go that's what I'm looking for
Oh God
I haven't gotten a single mount yeah
what am i doing
dragon hitter is ready in a minute huh
gamer guys says hi everyone hello man
how's it going good to see ya
oh heck yeah we got more mounts going on
excellent
cannons broken well one of them still
good that's good that's good
I haven't never been able to
successfully use a cannon in here it's
just way too hard I think I did once but
yeah it's it's not it's not the easiest
thing to do you know I'm gonna load up
this cannon see if I can make it work do
it Oh God let's go say it's the dragon
ate already that'd be the perfectly
stuff I'm sitting here waiting for it to
pop off oh my gosh ah jeez now it's
ready
we can get him back come on down okay we
we did the flash pod and he just ended
up dropping out of here and down the
cliff okay my cannon is loaded I just
need to get it in right
I'll pick a boy don't break my can then
just ah didn't do no it's still there
it's still there for now I just spent
like a minute loading man yeah yeah he's
just over there breathing staring at a
wall okay okay get him to hop down get
him to hop down okay okay I'm doing it
do it wait that's really weird yeah did
it hit him it broke two parts in the
ogre and I think it I think it hit both
I hope so saw two numbers pop oh okay I
I couldn't get a good angle on I
couldn't really see okay oh this is
perfect
that mist they only hit once at the ends
yeah that was like right where the tail
was let's me man
not worth it not worth it it isn't even
right ah
this morning he just jumped across the
whole room man imagine this was not
money for game of the year among Red
Dead Redemption two and God of War it
was yeah we uh we had like our top ten
all of them nominated for Game of the
Year with Monster Hunter was one of them
yeah we managed to get monster hunter
out there I'm a level of my I'm only
like something in the 40s for hunter
rank pretty low cuz I kind of like
stopped using this character that's that
that PC migration
[Music]
so Otis Karen's got to go pretty soon
that's gonna say he's been alive for a
very long time and he's very his pulse
is very weak those tail got knocked off
oh it still tika knocked off where'd it
go oh it's right there
yeah yeah Oh God
I'm gonna try and get this tail car
while function while it's right above
this dude that's the monster on our way
man
there we go I think
come on No
come on
what's going on a bit yeah yeah we also
did a lot of damage to the pickle boy as
well I think we did a lot of a lot of
work focusing again I think we can we
can get him fairly quickly after Shh
okay coming down with you
there it is all right he's gone new
rocks yet nope I'm just kind of hanging
out
oh I got a note here and plate stuck
around too long I was going for the car
I need to not die I need to not die
that just barely didn't hit me yeah and
that hit me but it's okay I got the
carved up okay I'm gonna put down a
health booster
I can't even
this one's been a real pain that is the
other one don't not that rough don't
jump on me
there we go
knocked him down knocked him out good
stuff
I got one left we did it and we haven't
no one's feeling up yet so that's good
sorry we were not painted at the chat we
work I into that for maybe that the
fight was intense people ask about the
assassins stuff we're currently doing
the quest to get it after we get this
quest done we will be able to get those
outfits and I'll show them off we'll get
one for each I think we can show while
we're doing mine
mom show my outfit you might want to
switch back because we can I think we
can show your screen I just wanna make
sure that that like looks correct you
know we can we could check it out yeah I
also think to show off the mantle you
might actually have to go into like a
hunt though I don't know if you can pull
it out Oh true that's okay we can do a
little small hunt or something yeah all
right oh the Rockstar set up so we could
do a another rock just gonna sit I'm
gonna sit right here
use bombs they're already there there
are yep the bombs are happening the
bombs happens okay get me in the middle
come on over out
yikes a little bit more now where I am
come on come on
lure them in their middle
no don't
okay okay no ah that timing is so tricky
it's a it's a smart one
ah like any new likes a tail
oh we got we got a mount I didn't even
realize oh nice
I love it I'm gonna use my mighty Hill
some damage boost
all right the down
tail
I saw that coming and I still went for
it putting down a help booster
we do the same nice
okay crime since why is there a scorpion
sign but no sub-zero these are the
questions I like that crime this is a
very important question
whoof
you know I'm uh I was born in November
so that makes me like a reptile you know
oh I see I see what's the clan what's
the name of the clan the ninja clan I
don't remember that like it's win
kwang-ho linkway I'm part of the link
way there you go
that's the one that sub-zero and then um
sektor and stuff Iran right yeah
I'm excited for a new Mortal Kombat meet
- I love Mortal Kombat yeah and that's
kind of really soon yeah that was uh
real quick they're like hey it's being
made else's come out in April I'm like
oh snap okay so I think actually um like
this month like next week or something
they're doing they're doing like a
community event where they're gonna be
shown the game on hmm oh yeah cuz we
haven't seen anything about sides that
it exists whoa so I'm very excited for
that game that should be great
so yeah you were saying earlier how you
hope this year is still a great year for
fighting games
yeah we're getting we're getting mortal
kombat so we're getting something then
cuz yeah we're fighting game fans and
last year was a killer year for fighting
games specifically anime players are so
many and they're all so good promises
yeah that's coming to switch I'm very
curious how that's gonna run yes aim
well with a fighting game you need to
run smooth so I guess how is it gonna
look right that is the other question
because Kombat 10 or X I guess it's a
good looking game yeah yeah there's a
lot of detail that game looks really
sharp
oh hey there ooh that cannon yep hates
cannons not a fan
ouch who wants to know if we've had a
weapon arc where we change what weapon
we use as our main weapon so you're
going through that right now switching
over to PC yep when I went to pcs which
ever to charge blade I kind of I'm kind
of the point where I I know what weapons
I like so I kind of just go back and
forth between a whole bunch yeah what I
when I my brother play and he was trying
to figure out he was debating between
the the longsword and then maybe the
concent clave and we were just saying
about like the way this game is designed
you wanna you want to learn every weapon
yeah like it's every weapon feels so
different and they're all like pretty
cool in their own way and so he was like
trying them all out in the like training
room and he's like these are all awesome
I want to I want to use all of these
they all feel so different and change
how you play like completely they do but
you might like one minute is something
to switch out for ya the next
consecutives cool I'd maybe do that I
kind of like the long story cuz I just
I'm the big fan of like giant katanas
yeah that's the thing that's an
aesthetic it's it's a good one okay let
me jump off I don't want to be on fire
anymore
I could not be on fire that would be
fantastic okay I'm gonna try and find a
good spot another Easter does that an
explosion yep it is yeah wow I was just
barely on the edge of that one oh don't
kill me don't kill me don't
oh do it again yikes do big Yanks oh my
god he's smacking me around yeah big
same
we just lost one dude was it one or was
it to just one okay we're still okay
I'm real happy that we managed to get
rid of all that build-up though and that
there's two explosions somebody uh
somebody mount him and then I can I can
get some bombs going if we can knock him
down I'll see if I can
come on come on hello I'm over here are
you going coming over to Maine
she knows he's like ah he's talking
about bombs yikes let me alone
you're he it's all about you it's female
yes I keep I keep miss speaking and
they're all good boys it's it's been a
rough time
oh cool cool cool okay ba ma maman Bom
Bom
that's blossom fireworks that's a ah
time so I forgot to put it in my
inventory sorry guys
blossom fireworks it is perfect I don't
think those do any damage but they look
great it's just some little motivational
for you guys fireworks going off the
Dragon Eaters gonna be good in a minute
okay that will actually be the useful
thing to use
now Jesus wants to know where the
Assassin's Creed is we're currently
doing the quest for it we'll have it
here in a sec almost there
okay
like this music guess it's a good song
Oh yikes Wow my health just suddenly
deteriorated come on yes wow that was
close
I got really nervous there do you need
goats in the main story to do this event
uh yes you would because the main story
is how you get to like high rank stuff
so yeah
dragon area can be is let's just bring
him over her over I know I'm keep doing
it I need to not do it yeah there it is
so let's go attack I would that I'm
scared
there's sleep we're awake asleep yeah
that's my bad
let me just roll boy boy boy boy I need
to heal hey we did it
watch we're gonna get three tickets off
of three feathers off of this one you
can build everything I hope so it'd be
great what quest are you doing this is
the quest to get the parts to build the
Assassin's Creed crossover gear so you
can get layered armor that makes you
look like byuk and you can also get a
special mantle that makes you look like
SEO and increases your attack damage
from hidden places which is a pretty
cool setup yeah
[Music]
I just saw a bike do a Hadoop yeah it's
real good pretty good that's that's good
crossover content we need this is the
type of uh this is what I'm looking for
he's a good punch it was a good a good
energy energy blasts heck yeah
alright that's okay
I'll take the layered armor I'll grab
that if you want to grab the mantle yeah
yeah yeah this is this is uh this is a
heck of a quest that you're fighting
some very high level real intense
monsters in it I need details on The
Witcher 3 event nothing outside of the
teaser we had yeah just a lot of
speculation but it's coming it's
happening it should be a good time I
grew through y'all said the bean stream
home doesn't release I was born at the
same time both platforms it's gonna be a
big problem I agree I hope they get that
together when you get our parity going
again like that's you know things like
destiny were able to kind of like get
that going self I hope they do all right
so I have to bring them to here yep
let's go to complete deliveries pending
becoming an assassin so this is the bike
one this is the hood I'm gonna go to the
back one oh I got some titles I can
actually label myself as an assassin
origins byuk pharaoh scarab stealth I
also get the Scarab mural and I got to
becoming an assassin pose so let's uh
let's just that out there we go the
assassins hood grab it change layered by
AK BAM look at that oh we got
backgrounds and poses yeah yeah that is
pretty cool and I can change the color
as well which is nice so
it could be the pink back I've always
wanted to be I'll go to the default
color though
well awesome that looks great I've got
I've got the the hood but I can't I
can't wear it I want to see the pose in
the oh yeah that's definitely worth
checking out some of the poses they've
added are really good so 24/7 Ally on
say on the house that's pretty good one
I forgot about that that's that's it
right there
I know I want to edit it not you so the
background we want
scarab there we go okay okay get that
hot Ubisoft trademark perfect that's
exactly love it I'm all about it
they couldn't give them an asset without
the trademark sticker oh pose here we go
these composes I forgot good these poses
are yeah yeah that's very good that's
good that's good [ __ ] that's good that's
good yeah I got mine were still Mega Man
1 which is why I saw Hadouken 1 Everdeen
ivory Oh him with the gun that's that's
too much that's too good foot by ik got
some it's packing heat oh I like this
one too I think this rise up it's like
yeah that's the assassin 1 put your cat
on your own the cat's the arm weights
right you send you but it's becoming
assassin it's so dumb this is great I'm
going that ebony and ivory one because
that's just yeah that's there's a lot of
attitude and that also I want to make
sure you properly see that Ubisoft
trademark it's really important really
to know where the bat that is so dumb
but I like this one a lot though it's
real real stupid your Mega Man one yeah
where you can like
yeah yeah like you actually have a
controller you're holding
yeah the Megaman wants the yeah that one
yeah then your your cat actually like
sits in the Yaak and I could show people
we're talking about here in the spa
yeah this one yeah the controller right
there and it's like I'm playing uh like
I'm really a Mega Man oh look at mega
Manning ah look at that perfect byuk
loves Mega Man that's its cannon it's
perfect
anyway yeah dude do we want to just go
into a hunt really quick yeah we can
show off the mantle for you and then I
think we'll call it good let's not even
let's just go into the yeah let's do a
really quick quest all right why don't
you uh quickly post something I'll post
a thing something small something easy
we're just gonna hop in there and
quickly do it then we'll call this a
stream yeah yeah yeah I'll just pick
this rat a bad one I got a special arena
special arena for ya yeah all right it's
up
I'm not even gonna eat food here we go
my man thong you do don't worry about
yeah I'm ready to go V Phoenix would
come by hang out well while we do it
Shizuku is gonna be there too to be a
good time I'm gonna force everyone to go
but doing it we're just here for the
right I don't think we're even gonna
hunt or do you want on them I mean it's
I think it's a low-rank Radovan so it'd
be really quick I'm down here we go okay
show me want to see it look one-one
second it's me gonna act second boom
you're at Z oh no this is just this is
just your top that's got weird but so if
you if you hide inside of like it's
weird that the pants yeah babe
if you hide in a bush do that's funny by
jumping out so actually I think I run
faster - okay well I definitely prefer
the the black one say a full full outfit
yeah I think I'm faster
I definitely have the right weapon for
this yeah I know maybe maybe it's
something else Krantz is kissing like
our character bees ah the perfect oh my
my fan fiction is coming to life
I love it do you know they still put
like they still do the like you you play
like you can unlock the old assassin
outfits yeah yeah stuff like you can
have like by a quick we're like Ezio's
and all Tigers and like they still do
that hi - eight thing I like that they
still like take those old outfits and
like put them in the new engines and
stuff and I think that's cool
this is gonna go by so fast he's gonna
die old quick as soon as I realize that
I'm knocking parts of his armor off with
my longsword with one hit that's what I
knew that's when you knew you'd become a
Master Assassin I'm done it
I'm the assassin
he's just falling apart everywhere it's
had a rough time
oh this is just brutal
there's nothing but it's just his jaw
oh my gosh Alvie Phoenix mountain also
forgot be Phoenix back yeah
got the tails gone well i'ma grab it
you've got a man you're gonna miss the
whole fight right I'll grab it small
done sorry he's here he just rolled
right over me perfectly that was great
surprised this isn't going any quicker
actually yeah feel like there you go
look I'm still dressed up like Ezio
excellent requiescat and patch a a bike
I don't know what is he say I don't know
what he says I there he's just pretty
angry in that game he's jealous about a
Sun and murders people anyway I think
that's gonna do it
yes that's real good is it we did it
there's some good Assassin's Creed
crossover contacts we got two bikes on
Ezio and then a regular Monster Hunter
person look like you're a character from
uh from a dynasty warriors yeah I'm into
it as young her hmm out of cow pee song
her is the only my dynasty or skydive
booboo
okay I can't escape booboo yeah uh thank
you everyone for we're all done with the
stream fantastic yeah
but thank you guys for hanging out with
us while we went into Monster Hunter and
got some really cool stuff really
appreciate it checking this out with us
yeah it was fun it's always fun on the
plot back in a monster hunter we'll
definitely be back when they do gerald
of Riverdale Gerald of Riverdale's
breakout appearance in Monster Hunter
world and also count on us being there
for the expansion when it happens later
on this year definitely was a good time
yeah we'll see you guys next time
goodbye everybody mwah thanks for tuning
in for our first stream diversity the
first first of many first of many sure
to subscribe [ __ ] oh come back please I
miss you I miss you if you don't come
back
hi guys
[Music]